today I'm excited because I'm making a
video that I've wanted to make for quite
a long time and it's a subject that's
close to my heart because it's about my
hometown I was born and raised in
Halifax Nova Scotia and as we film this
we're coming up to the hundredth
anniversary of one of the most major
events in the history of that city but
it's also an event that was marked
around the world because it was the
largest explosion made by human beings
in the pre-atomic
era key to understanding this story is
understanding the geography of Halifax
as a city and so I'll sketch it out here
the main part of Halifax is a peninsula
quite a funny shape in the wider area
and what made Halifax such an incredible
resource from you know for hundreds of
years is the larger picture and the
harbor and how it opens up into the
Atlantic Ocean so you have next to this
peninsula you have this deep and
sheltered Basin called the Bedford Basin
and then you have this tiny little
passage called the Narrows with a little
bump here and then this beautiful deep
Harbor you've got a few islands here
you've got a big ones here McNab's
island you've got a little one here and
so out here is the Atlantic Ocean over
here is the Bedford Basin this side is a
city the city called Halifax and on the
other side is a city that used to be
called Dartmouth now they're put
together in one Regional Municipality
but we'll call them separate sides to
keep the name contrack key to this story
is this narrow little passage here which
is actually called the Narrows let me
set the scene for you 100 years ago
it's 1917 December world war 1 is fully
in force and this is an incredibly
strategic point hundreds of ships could
fit in this nice protected Basin and
then be shepherded over the North
Atlantic in convoy to Europe it's the
morning of December 6 1917 Halifax is
waking up it's a very busy town it's got
a big naval
presents is got a big army presence so
the night before every night in fact
submarine nets would have come down
across the harbor so to protect all the
ships in this part of the basin from
u-boat attack submarine nets would have
gone down across here and across here
and limited the traffic in and out of
the harbor and so we now have to
introduce two boats to our story number
one is the emo this is a Norwegian
registered Belgian relief ship so this
was a neutral ship that was tasked with
carrying supplies to give relief to
civilians on the continent that had been
devastated by war so this is sitting
here in the basin it's been sitting
there for a while
and it's getting impatient it's meant to
be leaving on the fifth but by the night
of the fifth it still hasn't been loaded
up with coal and the submarine nets are
down it's stuck
it wants to go to New York coming in
from New York is the mole blown and this
is a friendship and unbeknownst to
almost anyone in Halifax it's caring
it's loaded it's packed to the brim with
explosives
so it's also intending to go across
North Atlantic and help with the war
effort it arrives too late to get
through the submarine nets so it spends
the night over here next to McNab's
Island what happens the next morning
these two ships both want to get through
the harbor in different directions
according to the rules of the road they
should be passing port side to port side
which means they should come across like
this navigating carefully and slowly to
get through the Narrows however that's
not what happens the emo takes this
corner wide to avoid an oncoming ship
while the Moblin is keeping its station
on the correct side at this point there
are a few kilometers apart and remember
it's 1917 and the the conventional way
of communicating is through whistles so
the mon blown whistles first that means
by rights they should retain
right-of-way and they say one whistle
I'm staying
I am the emo unbelievably responds with
a cross signal to whistles no I'm
keeping this station now we have a
problem the emo is moving quite fast
it's not loaded with anything so it's
sitting high in the water and it's
moving probably faster than the speed
limit the mobile all cuts its speed
again
one whistle even moves over slightly to
the starboard side the Dartmouth sighs
I'm staying here - whistles from the emo
no I'm staying here at this point heads
would have turned the first exchange
people are used to that background noise
the second exchange people would have
known that something unusual was
happening and would have stopped to look
and at that point it's quite clear that
these two ships are heading straight
towards each other in this narrow
channel with very little room left to
maneuver remember how nervous the
captain of the mo blow must be he knows
what's in his cargo cuts his engines
says ok I've got to do something to
mitigate this situation cuts his engines
which causes the ship to drift towards
the Halifax side had that been the only
thing that happened happened the
situation would have been avoided it
would have been a near miss but at the
same time the emo also cuts its engines
and because it's sitting so high in the
water its propeller has really little
purchase and it has very little
maneuverability and so now a collision
is absolutely inevitable and so the emo
impacts the montt law broadside like
this even then a fairly minor collision
in the grand scheme of things what makes
this story really interesting is to
understand fully what exactly was all on
the move long we have a variety of
things all designed to blow up we have
two hundred twenty-seven thousand
kilograms of TNT have 1.6 million
kilograms of wet picric acid as well as
544
and kilograms of dry picric acid on top
of that 56,000 kilograms of gun cotton
and strapped in barrels to the top of
the ship we had 223 thousand kilograms
of benzyl and monochlorobenzene so let's
talk about what these things actually
are the benz all the monochlorobenzene
they're petroleum byproducts and they're
used sort of in the production of picric
acid which let's talk about a minute
they're flammable they are in danger of
catching a fire what's packed in the
holes however is something more
dangerous now TNT at that time was
becoming to be used in the production of
munitions it was largely replacing
picric acid as the explosive powder used
in munitions because picric acid is so
incredibly volatile and dangerous so
while the new TNT was perhaps less
powerful as a as an explosive it was
relatively speaking much easier and
safer to handle than the picric acid
we've now got our two ships then they
sort of are maneuvered apart okay so
they're now separate the mobile all
drifting towards the Halifax side in the
initial collision a fire started on deck
now it may have been from the sparks
caused by the metal hulls grating
against each other it was likely caused
by the the simple you know detonation of
a few grains of picric acid
but once the fire took hold all of these
flammable things on the top deck started
to catch fire and so now you've got a
ship on fire this is mainly the benzo
this is mainly the benzyl yeah
it's spewing off thick oily black smoke
and people are starting to become
worried because the ship is drifting
towards the Halifax side it's heading
straight for some of the wooden piers
that are the heart of the harbour
business okay so they're worried that
there's gonna be a fire on shore the
worried about pollution in the harbor
from oil that would be bad enough on the
ship the crew immediately know that
there is absolutely nothing that they
can do to stop this ship from blowing up
I should mention that sent in sensible
non-war times if you were carrying a
ship like that you would be flying flags
all over the place
Thanks you know danger stay away for
obviously reasons you don't want to do
that any more time so very few people
actually knew that it was a ship loaded
with high munitions the crew immediately
seeing how futile the situation was got
into their lifeboats they start moving
towards the Dartmouth side they're
shouting all the way there shouting
warnings to people but the warnings are
either not heard or they're not
understood because they're in French so
now we've got the situation where the
ship is on fire it's now nestled against
pier six on the hellofax side the fire
is raging
the benzol and then later the
monochlorobenzene
is reaching boiling points those barrels
are shooting up into the air and
exploding so it's a big spectacle people
are rushing to windows they're rushing
down the streets to see what's going on
what's happening in the hold is that
these are hermetically they're carefully
constructed holds to hold these high
explosives the fire is raging
the temperatures are increasing and
weather eventually it's from the
incredibly high temperatures and
pressures inside these sealed
compartments or whether it's an impact
from these exploding barrels coming down
and hitting the deck detonation occurs
the picric acid explodes sends a
shockwave through
the neighboring barrels the hold explode
sends an airbrush the rest of the ship
one by one the holes full of picric acid
dry picric acid the wet picric acid and
the gun cotton which have the water
inside them has evaporated turning them
into high explosives as well detonates
as well you've now got a ship with three
kilotons of high explosives which is now
the largest bomb that human beings have
ever made and at 9:04 on december 6 1917
it exploded
well instantly there's a massive
fireball that reaches five thousand
degrees Celsius that's nearly the
temperature of the surface of the Sun
and engulfs the neighboring streets but
people in the land a nice people in the
land incinerated the mold blown three
million kilograms of iron hull destroyed
white-hot shards of iron are flowing
through the air faster than bullets and
rained down on the neighboring area most
devastating was the air blast traveling
a thousand metres per second through the
narrow streets
it causes unimaginable devastation to
houses to human beings to the whole
whole city remember that many of these
people are standing looking at this
spectacle lining the steep hills look
leading down to the harbor looking out
at the burning ship when it explodes all
of the windows in the city exploded as
well and most of them are driven inwards
horrific Lee injuring people everything
that wasn't immediately blown up as a
structure catches on fire it's a huge
firestorm throughout the city as the air
blast goes out and the gas is cool the
air rushes back in again and tornados
full of debris start sweeping through
the streets the one point four thousand
kilogram anchor of the Mont Blanc was
flown kilometres away way over on the
other side of the city
and can still be seen today where it
landed going back to what happened in
the harbor the expanding gases push the
water away forming a hole in the in the
water in the harbor that just like when
you throw something into a pond and and
you see the ripples rebound caused a
huge geyser to appear in the harbor that
sucked
water away from the opposite shores and
then sent a huge tsunami funneled down
these narrow harbor walls reaching 20
feet in height causing even more
devastation at the end of that morning
you had 2,000 people dead
9,000 people severely injured 12,000
homes destroyed and every single
building within a 12 mile radius damaged
you can find out more about the Halifax
Explosion
including some links in the video
description and I'll also have details
about more from this interview with dr.
gray also thanks to Neil Barnes from our
chemistry channel periodic videos for
helping out with some of these
demonstrations and you can find out more
about periodic videos also in the video
description
you